[Music]
please welcome back to our show the very
funny kyle kinnain
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what's happening guys
uh
guys i uh i don't know what love is
uh but i was at a bar in texas and i
overheard a girl order a thousand island
iced tea
if you don't understand why that's
incorrect right away
don't worry i didn't pick it up either
i was like that sounds refreshing why
don't you make it two of them oh hold on
a second somebody confused their salad
dressings and their cocktails
and my only regret in life was that i
did not have a ring to propose at that
moment
because she had first wife material
written all over her
i know it wasn't gonna last but you know
you see a special lady you're like hey
let's say me and you make a mess out of
the next 15 months and go our separate
ways
uh
i don't know if this happened to me
reason have you ever met somebody that
enraged you so much
you actually had to respect them for it
this actually had me two weeks ago here
in l.a i was at a bar on a friday night
and the man sitting next to me
sent back a mimosa i'll just say that
again
a man at a bar on a friday night sent
back a mimosa do you know what you have
to do to send back a mimosa you have to
order a mimosa
this was a friday night at a dirty bar
in hollywood this wasn't brunch there
were no fluffy eggs and jazz
this man ordered champagne and orange
juice and for the first time in my life
i actually thought you know what i think
i can kick his ass
then he sent it back and then that's
when i knew i was in the presence of an
assassin because only
somebody with that confidence can send
back a mimosa can poo poo that drink and
be like no you do it again i'm gonna sit
here and wait for you to get that right
somebody say something to me about the
mimosa ask me about the mimosa i'll
twist your head right off
i know i did i just finished my bloody
mary and i got out of there
i uh
oh
about bloody mary's i don't know if you
realize this like do you know that if
you go in the bathroom and you turn off
all the lights and you say bloody mary
into the mirror three times
your dad can hear you through the vents
and he'll think you're gay all through
junior highs
make sure you're alone before you start
conjuring up spirits so there's going to
be some awkward formative years for you
it's the holidays i like the holidays
it's fun i like all all the stories and
everything my favorite story is uh it's
the three wise men uh everybody knows
that story you know three wise men came
bearing gifts for baby jesus one brought
frankincense one brought murr and the
third one brought gold what they don't
tell you in the bible's the one that
brought him the gold was like all right
listen but this is for your birthday and
christmas okay
the combo president the cute joke
conquering can do coot jokes it's all
right
i uh i live here in uh los angeles i've
lived here for nine years it's uh
i love it here it's weird it's the
little things that why i call it home
and why i miss it when i'm away and it's
a strange thing like i moved to southern
california i found out that i love
hiking and more so than than the hiking
itself what i love is that no matter how
far you get into the woods or the
outdoors of los angeles county no matter
how many hours you hike up into a
mountain there will still be gang signs
scratched into everything
and that is that is heartwarming to me
do you understand that because that
means all these terrifying gangs that
we're so scared of they're out there
taking nature hikes like you and me
they're out there doing it
i'm spending a hundred dollars at rei to
get the right boots and a camelback to
carry hydration they're doing an
oversized dickie shorts not even getting
their indeed is scuffed up
i imagine they go up there it's like a
team-building exercise you know they're
up there and you know the elder
statesman the group calls the youngest
one around he thinks he's about to get
jumped in but really it's just a botany
lesson he's about to get you know he's
like all right little puppet check it
out this right here it's a eucalyptus
tree right
now a eucalyptus tree that's a
coniferous tree which means it retains
its waxy leaves year round it's unlike a
deciduous tree which is going to go
ahead and shed those leaves every fall
like a little [ __ ]
now i'm gonna ask you are you a
deciduous tree or are you a conifer yeah
okay now don't forget when we hike down
walk backwards a little so you don't get
shin splints okay
that's it for me thank you very much
hey kyle
that's
thanks hilarious today